so we're here at the birthplace of
thorium the gsib Institute in dumb start
where the ions of this element were
first made behind me and all along is
the accelerator where the ions were
accelerated to make atoms of this
element first of all this machine can
accelerate any iron you want and so the
idea when you're trying to make an
element is you take something like lead
which is quite a heavy nucleus and you
bang into it the nucleus with the atomic
number that will add up to what you want
so in this case of Boreum we want
element 107 and we accelerate them
together and where they hit every so
often once every few days you make an
atom of the element you want and thorium
was the first of these super-heavy
elements to be made here in Germany in
dumb start there's some isotopes some
versions of the nucleus different
versions of the nucleus can have
different numbers of neutrons always the
same protons the the shortest-lived one
is only 12 milliseconds that's a very
short amount of time but the other one
is as a lifetime of 17 seconds somebody
who was a better runner than me could
run the length of this accelerator 120
meters much quicker than that once it
was made there's an argument about what
they should call of it the scientist
here wanted to name it after Niels Bohr
the famous Danish physicist who was the
first one who produced a nice structure
for the atom how it was made with the
nucleus with electrons going round in
quantized orbits and the international
union of pure and applied chemistry
which decides on the names and says
whether you can have it or not
said you couldn't call it Niels Bohr Ian
because never before that people use the
Christian name of a scientist as well as
their surname
but the scientists said here said well
Boreum sounds rather like boron and
people might get muddled so it was
decided let's let the danish scientist
vote and they voted for Boreum niels
bohr was very famous for many of his
predictions he worked out or predicted
that there would only be about a hundred
elements in the periodic table and it
was based on the idea that as you put
more and more protons positively charged
particles into the nucleus of an atom it
will get more and more unstable and he
reckoned that round about a hundred with
where it would become completely
unstable and it was not a bad guess when
Niels Bohr got his Nobel Prize there was
great celebration in Denmark and the
Carlsberg brewery gave him a house next
door to the brewery with a pipe coming
through the wall so he could have beer
whenever he wanted there's still a
question with this name boron and Boreum
because what happens when you start
having the salts of these because borate
and borate sounds just the same nobody
hears the h when you say it so it's been
decided that the salt ciborium will be
called boriates rather than 4:8 so that
people won't be confused now you may say
that silly because how can you do
chemistry on things that are shortly and
it turns out that if an atom lives for
shorter time at one second you can
already start doing chemistry and in the
case of Orion that they have done some
chemistry reacting with oxygen and
chlorine and have observed the behavior
of what is the optical ride of Boreum
and shown that it really fits into the
group of the periodic table where we
want to put it